there's a woman
[Music]
in prince william county in the school
district there she showed up to the
school board to to
grill the members of the school board
and to speak out against the
superintendent of the school board there
this woman had a great riff
on the inefficacy of masks
and the insanity of masking up the
little kids
but then she showed the political
corruption here too she pushed back on
the narrative that so many politicians
have leaned on which is look there's
nothing we can do we want look we're
just following the scientists look we're
just following we're just following
orders okay and so you got to mask your
kids up and and we just have to go along
and do it that's an excuse they're
they're hiding behind other people to
push policies that they want and this
mother has had enough
on november 15th of last year i had the
privilege of speaking with dr mcdade for
10 minutes following the crt town hall
meeting during that discussion which was
friendly and cordial i asked what she as
superintendent could do to get the kids
out of masks dr mcday told me that she
would if she could but that her hands
were tied by then governor northam's
executive order mandating face coverage
and if it weren't for that things would
be different well tonight things are
different
and i'd like to ask you dr mcday tonight
what has changed and what do you plan on
doing now that your hands are untied i'm
in fact i'm asking all of you to step up
the way other leaders who have who have
and are ending coveted restrictions by
the day what when will you what will it
take you are on the losing side of
history and it's time to make that right
before these children now thank you
be still my beating heart oh my gosh oh
i just i just want to watch it again i
want to watch it on on loop you can see
in the
board room that they're meeting in there
are all these big signs up in front of
the school they say thank you school
board
great job keep up the oh so what thank
you school board
it doesn't sound like those
parents in the audience are thanking the
school board
now in the room it's it sounds like
prime minister's questions out in in the
united kingdom
so forget that it sounds like a wwe
match
yeah wow yeah get him you drag him girl
it's so
there is obviously so much popular
support
for the parents
who are taking control of their
children's education pushing back on
these psycho administrators and these
leftist insane politicians and saying no
enough is enough take off the stupid
masks stop trying to make me inject my
kid with the experimental drug to maybe
possibly but probably not protect
against the virus that doesn't pose any
particularly grave threat to them
shut up you awful superintendents and
your principals and your school board
members
and get out
because we're going to control education
now this is such a great issue the
people running the education system are
completely full of it
this is a great issue where it
kind of like joe rogan actually joe
rogan transcends political boundaries he
is a liberal but he appeals to lots of
conservatives he appeals to some
leftists and some bernie bros too he's
got a really kind of broad appeal the
same thing with this parents movement
it's got a really broad appeal
it it's not just the rock-ribbed
conservatives it's it's any mother
any parent who doesn't want their kid to
be victimized by psychos in school and
there's a whole lot of that going around
by the way you got to ring the bell
subscribe that way you'll get
notifications if for whatever reason you
do not get notifications for our videos
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in the michael
knowles show subscribe leave a five star
review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you